the picture of britain having largely
moved on from racial and ethnic
inequality
isn't one recognized in cities like
bristol ranked among the country's most
unequal societies
last summer the statue of a prominent
17th century slave owner was toppled
amid
nationwide black lives matter protests
that prompted the government's review of
disparities in
education employment health and criminal
justice
it's disgraceful i mean everything else
leading up to this point has said
completely different
things even government commission
reports we're definitely not
a beacon for the world if we look at our
incarceration figures they're worse than
america
per capita if we look at debts in
custody
if we look at stop and search and and
drug stops and searches
they are disproportionate
to the crimes being kitted and they are
focused on black
men especially these are the front doors
beyond the shutters
welcome to the big academy anton brown
believes deprived communities must help
themselves
with no schooling beyond the age of 12
he founded a successful cleaning
business
became a mentor to troubled youngsters
and is now building a community skills
academy for those
also excluded from education so you're
giving them 100
everybody can come here from parents
children and they can become something
you don't have to feel that oh i can't
achieve anything in life
based off of my color because i don't
let that stop me
and if i'm a young man and i'm saying
i'm not gonna let that stop me who comes
from the same
the prime background a little education
and i'm still winning that means they
can do exactly the same thing
this is where the statue of edward
colston once stood
when protesters brought it down last
year it sparked intensive scrutiny of
this country's racial past
of injustices that led to inequalities
that persist today
but the government's report seems to be
a direct rebuke of all of that
the well-intentioned idealism it says of
those young people who claim the country
is still
institutionally racist is not borne out
by the evidence
ask these young people and they'll tell
you the evidence
is plain to see in this area in the city
area there's no youth center
you can see the social equality that
when you're growing up you don't have
any place to go to learn how to play
football or basketball or music or enjoy
yourself and meet
new friends and build friendship and get
new skills
but that is a picture barely recognized
by the government's report
jonah al jazeera bristol